what are your thoughts on the stimulus
and kind of a lot of the monetary policy
is coming out right now in response to
you know kind of market conditions at
the moment there's areas in very
opinionated on other things fall I'm one
in the middle I think this is hard it's
hard because there's so much uncertainty
you know we outlined this we did a piece
called investing in the time of corona
where we said look here's a bull case
and we said governments around the world
respond everyone's doing testing self
quarantine works there's treatments
develop hey maybe the malaria medication
works a vaccine comes along coronavirus
is never seen again essentially or it's
reduced markets hit all-time highs by
year end right then you have the bear
case which is government's respond but
it's too late the virus is everywhere it
goes exponential you know people are
despondent treatments don't work a
vaccine is two years away the summer
comes around has some relief and then
the bockris comes back in the fall and
it happens again and markets go down
another 50% like you have to be able to
hold those two ideas in your head at the
same time maybe not as equally plausible
but as possible and we talk about this a
lot with valuations and we used to say
with valuations last year we do speeches
they say this is the stock market is
trading at 32 what's most likely most
likely is it drifts back down mean
reverse to around average in which case
you'll get 4% or 1% a year
could it go back up at 45 sure can you
have to plan for that scenario we'd say
what how does how does it get there how
does it get to a hundred P ratio maybe
Elon Musk invents free energy it could
also go back down to five which has
happened before P ratio which case
stocks declined 80% what would cause
that who knows could be something we're
experiencing so you have to hold both
thoughts in your head and prepare for
both outcomes what's most likely to
happen something in the middle so
playing blackjack you know most likely
events or statistical the outliers
always happen you know there's the idiot
the end of the table that you know hits
a 19 and gets it to play says see I told
you
or something like that but unlikely so
you prepare for both to be somewhat anti
fragile and the way that I do it and we
didn't really touch on it is the hardest
part of the public market stuff is
staying the course
so buy-and-hold investing works great
you have a over a hundred years of it
working great the problem with buying
hold investing is that the stocks bonds
real assets is that all the bad stuff
happens at the same time so you have a
bear market you have a recession people
losing their jobs their account balances
go down it's all happening at once so
the hardest part with buying hold is
usually during the bear market people
sell on the way down or to the point
where they just can't take it anymore
right but it traditionally if you hold
an ad over time it's a great investing
strategy the flip side which we didn't
really talk about which is half my
investment portfolio which is larger
than any institution in the world that
I've ever talked to is in trend
following strategies and that can mean a
lot of different things but the very
basic is you're investing in a market
that is going up you're out when it's
going down you could use something like
a 200-day moving average we have a paper
coming out that investing in markets at
all-time highs is actually a great idea
or a stock like say percent of all-time
highs
the problem with trend following so you
can apply that to an entire portfolio we
wrote an old paper back in 2006 in the
journal wealth management that
successfully navigated the global
financial crisis and I didn't think I'd
ever see anything like that again in my
lifetime and turn off that portfolio
which was scope basic it looked at 200 a
hour 10 month moving average on updates
once a month on stocks foreign stocks
bonds REITs commodities and it exits
each of those when it's in a downtrend
going into March it would have been a
hundred percent cash and bonds so who
knows how this is going to play out but
the thing with Trin Fong is that it's
also hard to follow it's hard to follow
because it goes through long periods of
underperformance the entire 20 teens
anything other than buy and hold US
stocks struggled and there's old I can't
remember if Warren
Senator Charlie said it but they talk
about you know the emotions of fear and
greed is not what drives markets but the
biggest thing being envy and so the
problem with trim falling is that if
you're underperforming and chopping
along when all your neighbors are making
hay in stock markets you're not gonna
stick with it but the beauty of this
approach is what we call the Trinity
portfolio which is what I do with all my
public assets put it into one fund and
and by the way listeners I think this is
really important because a lot of people
don't know this the vast majority of
mutual fund managers depending on the
category it's like 50 to 90 percent have
nothing invested in their own funds zero
dollars if you go up to even a hundred
grant even less I put all my money into
our own components we have eleven but
half is in my hold and half is in trend
falling and why does that work for me
because in a year like 2019 I am so
happy to have a big chunk of my money
and buy and hold as markets wrong you
know up in the world in 2020 I'm happy
to have a trend following allocation
that markets in depending on the fun to
use we some of our some of other
people's either go to cash and bonds or
they'll straight up short some of these
asset classes and if you look at managed
futures most of those are having a
pretty good year many of those are up
and so the combination of the two it's
like a yin-yang thank God we have
trend-following in 2020 because if it
does get worse if we do have this bear
case hopefully I'm protected but if
markets rip back up we find some
treatments and the bull case happens and
thank God I have the the buy-and-hold
side and this lets me behave Bogle used
to say you put half in cash in half and
bonds he said because half the time you
spent worried did too much in stocks and
the other time you spend yet worried
till you get too much in bonds or too
little or vice versa it's the same thing
so that works for me it may not work for
a lot of people the one other thing that
so as far as your question I answer it
as an investor but as a policy question
it's really tough man you know I think a
lot of hopefully this is a short
thing I read last night at the Imperial
College report and do not read that if
you want to go to sleep or or not have
huge anxiety and depression for the next
six months we just don't know and so
look I think that is the government's
responsibility and the private sector
hopefully can help as much and try to
find treatments but it's to backstop
those in need when you have something
that's totally under control it's not
the backstop the [ __ ] cruise line and
excuse me but it's the backstop
individuals that are you know in the
restaurant industry the service
industries the people health care
workers that still have to go to work
god bless them you know you and I are
lucky enough to be able to do this sort
of job remote how they do that I don't
you know whether it's universal basic
income whether it's incentives I'll
leave that to the to the lawmakers I
don't know the best answer but there's
probably a sensible basic idea that
works yeah I am I wrote the today about
the unemployment levels and I went back
and I looked at like Great Depression
and kind of really tried to understand
the unemployment levels there one of the
data points that just blew me away was
in 1929 right before started in kind of
August 29 unemployment was at 3.1
percent right so very similar to where
we are today and it kind of ramped up
over from 29 to 33 up to that 25 percent
number that everyone know always kind of
you know highlights and yells and
screams about but in the second and
third year it was like eight point seven
percent and then fifteen percent and so
those are still very big numbers right
but they're not 25 percent and I started
doing some back of the envelope math
just seeing the unemployment kind of
multiples ever say so Ohio Minnesota New
Jersey except they're all reporting you
know in some cases 7 to 10 x increases
on unemployment claims over the last
couple of days you know beginning of
this week and who knows if that
sustainable who knows if that's not just
kind of one-time thing or or whatever
but when you start to look at this
you're like look you know sitting around
a three point five percent unemployment
rate anything above that can bring some
and I'm right there with you I think
that like you've got to figure out how
do you help these people especially when
you're asking restaurants to shut down
you're asking bars to shut down etc you
know it's just I hope that we don't kind
of lose sight of the small business
owner right who's not sitting on tons of
cash they're not worried about stock
buybacks they're worried about how do I
get you know to next month and continue
to you know make money for my family or
their staff I've got multiple friends
that own restaurants or kind of
hospitality type stuff and they're
literally like look at the fire hat you
know half to all of my staff in order
just to Katti to not have to go into
bankruptcy because my cash flow or
revenue went from you know a lot to zero
because I literally am shutting down
it's just a really kind of crazy time so
I think we've ever really seen something
like this before